long queues for fuel and for food
as the public comes to terms with
reality after the unrest
a picture is emerging
of a power struggle within kazakhstan's
political elite
in protests this week anger was directed
at independent kazakhstan's first
president 81 year old noor sultan
nazarbayev
old man get out they chanted
when those protests turned violent in
almaty nazarbayev was removed from the
powerful position he still occupied
chair of the security council
now his loyal associate karim masimov
fired from his role as chief of national
security has been charged with high
treason
nazarbayev hand-picked kasim jomat
tokayev as his successor in 2019 but did
not relinquish power
both men played a leadership role
attending international meetings
together as recently as last month
that has now changed
we're now entering
the tokyo era
like if this guy is going to be in
charge
because he's not going to put his own
man in charge he's going to have his own
government in charge so
he got rid of all the people who were
hanging over for the prior regime
the swift deployment of csto security
forces three thousand six hundred
russian-led troops is a clear sign to
kiev has moscow's backing
they are now helping to strengthen his
position
in north sultan the capital renamed
after nazarbayev state media no longer
mentions his name
internet blackouts have made it
difficult to gauge public reaction
i finally reached a political activist
via telegram he didn't want to be named
this informational chaos
we're kind of lost
because we have a lot of rumors people
say that azerbaijan has left country
that his relative left country
there is a power shift
all these stories and theories are based
on this lack of information
rumors
and official propaganda
those rumors only adding to the
uncertainty that now dominates life in
kazakhstan
robin forrester walker al jazeera
paul murphy is a member of the irish
parliament to the people before prophet
party and he was previously a member of
the european parliament involved in
human rights issues in kazakhstan he
says long-existing inequalities have
fueled the protests
kazakhstan is a country with enormous
natural wealth in terms of oil and gas
reserves and exploited by not only
russian oil companies but also western
oil companies chevron and so on and also
of course exploited by or the benefits
of which go to those at the very top of
the society in kazakhstan so this
massive wealth on the one hand side by
side with extreme poverty including for
those workers who are actually
generating
this wealth
and i think that that is the backdrop
combined with a very brutal
authoritarian regime that brooks
no disagreement no opposition parties
and so really the the fuel price rises
as i understand it where the straw that
broke the camel's back and now you have
an uprising to attempt to overthrow the
dictatorship obviously of games now
within the dictatorship of different
factions trying to maneuver for a
position and but certainly the feeling
that i'm getting from the ground is a
sense that the whole regime has to go
that the oil wealth should be under the
control of um ordinary people of
working-class people in in kazakhstan
and used for their benefit i think it is
really a fight to the end between the
regime and the uprising and clearly the
regime is very concerned that's
reflected in the internal struggles that
are taking place and but also the
brutality with which they're prepared to
respond